AS WE GO TO
OUR NEXT GAME, DISCONTINUED
PORNO MAGS.
DISCONTINUED PORNO MAGS.
YOU GODDAMN KIDS, YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW EASY YOU GOT IT.
BEFORE THE INTERNET, WE ALL HAD
TO SETTLE FOR WHATEVER RANDOM
DIRTY MAGAZINES WE COULD GET OUR
MASTURBATORY HANDS ONTO.
AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT
AIRBRUSHED PLAYBOY CRAP, EITHER.
I MEAN THE GRITTY STUFF, THE
REAL STUFF, THE BIG, PENDULOUS
BOOBS WITH THE NIPPLES POINTING
DOWN LIKE HOMER EYEBALLS.
AND BOOBS THAT COULD FEED AN
ENTIRE ALPACA FARM, THEY WERE SO
BIG.
AND BUSHES SO THICK YOU COULD
HIDE A WEATHER VANE IN 'EM.
I'M TALKING ABOUT MAGAZINES LIKE
JUGGS, WITH TWO GS.
OR THE ALWAYS-TASTEFUL BEAVER
HUNT.
UH...
WHERE EVERY COVER GIRL LOOKS
LIKE A DEAD-EYED FORMER CINNABON
EMPLOYEE.
>> WE HAD BEAVER HUNT MAGAZINE
IN CANADA, BUT IT'S COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT,
COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
COME UP WITH AS MANY NAMES FOR
DISCONTINUED, SLEAZY PORNO MAGS
AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN IN 60
SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
YEAH, STEVE?
>> COPS & THROBBERS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
PAUL.
>> QUEEFERS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
STEVE.
>> SQUIRTERS QUARTERLY.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
JON.
>> HEY, WHERE'D THAT CUCUMBER
GO?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
STEVE.
>> DISCERNING FISTS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
THAT'S...
PAUL.
>> STICKY PAGES.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
STEVE.
>> BIG OL' BEEFERS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
JON.
>> USE THIS FOR MASTURBATING
YOUR PENIS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
STEVE.
>> HAIRY AREOLAS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
OH, YOU MEAN HAIREOLAS?
>> HAIREOLAS.
>> HARDWICK: J-JON.
>> PUBES & FALLOPIAN TUBES.
>> HARDWICK: THAT'S SO SPECIFIC!
STEVE.
>> RANK UNDERCARRIAGE.
NOW WITH SCRATCH 'N' SMELL.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
PAUL.
>> CHODE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
JON.
>> HILLARY'S MYSTERY BOX.
>> HARDWICK: POINT... (LAUGHS)
OH, MY GOD, POINTS.
DEFINITELY POINTS.